in a city forever associated with
appeasing germany
allies gather to forge unity and resolve
against russia as events move fast in
ukraine a gloomy assessment from the
prime minister as i speak to you today
we do not fully know what president
putin
intends
but the omens are grim and that is why
we must stand strong
together
just a second i think
i think
cyber attack
can can can i have another one
for translation
yes but maybe you maybe you see russian
here but they're here
a telling joke from ukraine's president
haunting this conference the knowledge
russia could carry on playing the west
indefinitely
there is a playbook
of russian
aggression
and this playbook
is too familiar to us all
russia will plead
ignorance and innocence
it will create
false pretext
for invasion
we've heard the same warnings being made
here in munich for weeks now and they
are clearly not deterring russian malign
activity the fear is of both an imminent
invasion but also a protracted crisis
that could test the west for weeks to
come
the americans say putin has already
decided to invade
not necessarily says the prime minister
i think what's happening in at the
moment in donbass is exactly what uh we
would expect to happen the kind of
provocations uh that the russians engage
in uh generally and i'm afraid this
could well be the prelude to uh to
bigger action the americans seem to
think he has decided is our intelligence
different to theirs i think that
certainly things are in motion but the
question is whether it can all be
pulled back
but members of the prime minister's own
party fair ukraine is being let down
there is i'm afraid an awkward question
hanging here
why does the might of nato not have the
ability to prevent a europe european
democracy from being invaded
the west can't afford to drop its guard
but it's already placed limits on how
far it will go to defend ukraine how
long can its unity last and how long can
ukraine hold out against russia's
destabilizing tactics
dominic waghorn sky news munich